for more on what we can expect from the
FBI's investigation we're joined now by
Manny Gomez
he's a former FBI agent and president of
Mg security services Manny thank you for
joining us thank you for having me so
the Democrats got their FBI background
check investigation whatever you want to
call it Cavanaugh has been through six
of these my question is that Republicans
seem to suggest that their committee
investigators to do just a good as job
as the FBI is that true committee
investigators may be good the FBI is the
best that's why they have the reputation
that they have and that's all they do
what will the FBI do now many the FBI is
gonna be tracking down everybody that
was at the party interviewing them
asking them what they saw what they
heard even rumors documenting everything
they will certainly talk to dr. Ford to
judge Cavanaugh and they might polygraph
certain people that they think are not
forthright in their questioning keep in
mind that lying to an FBI agent is a
fowling
and so they're going to be warning
people to be forthright in these in this
investigation
you mentioned the polygraph but this
isn't a criminal investigation so what
tools beyond that do they have in order
to either compel people to speak with
them or to find out information well
you're right it's not a criminal
investigation they don't have subpoena
power certainly in a week's time they
can't get that but certainly they could
uncover by peeling the onion and talking
to as many people as possible that was
in that party in that house and many
those those theoretical witnesses don't
have to talk to the FBI do they no they
don't no they don't but as we see more
and more people are coming forward more
and more people want to participate on
either side mostly on the side of Judge
Cavanaugh numerous of his classmates
have come forward in writing saying
whatever their opinion is of him and
those are the people that they're going
to be talking to and asking them who
else was at that party who else was in
that house
then they have to seek out and talk to
those people as well to close the loop
the FBI way is to dot all the i's and
cross all the t's so they have to do
that in a very efficient and effective
manner together that week enough there
is that week I would suggest no but this
is coming right from the Senate right
from the President of the United States
so director director Cray was already
prepped and ready for this and I'm sure
he told all his uh deputy directors and
all the field offices to be primed and
ready for this because more likely than
not it was going to happen okay there is
a chance though that there is no
corroborating evidence that comes up in
this investigation but could the FBI
come up with evidence to show that some
of the things that Judge Cavanaugh said
in that hearing were not so on the ball
sure we have seen certain somewhat
inconsistencies with his testimony and
so they could definitely drill in and
make no mistake about it they are
definitely just going to drill in on
what was said at these hearings and what
allegedly happened at this party so
they're going to use all their
significant resources to drill in on
this date on this party and try to
ascertain the the truth and everything
that has been said at these hearings and
everything that everybody has said it
quickly as was pointed out in these
hearings the FBI doesn't actually make
conclusions on these investigations do
they they make conclusions if it's a
criminal matter
they will not on this because it is not
they will simply do the the
investigation and submit their findings
to the Senate and the president all
right Manny Gomez thank you so much for
being with us important we appreciate it